We're flying in a guest newsy, right into the desk.
(mimics airplane landing)
And she is a co-anchor at our affiliate station,
Fox 5 San Diego.
Please welcome a woman who I personally invited here.
We did it, she showed up, we made it happen.
Shally Zomorodi.
(audience cheering)
I got too much A on your name, Zomoray.
No, it's beautiful, it's perfect.
I cannot believe I'm sitting here next to you.
I'm so glad we're here together.
I'm so happy.
Before we get started on the news,
when last time I talked to you,
I said "Can I bring you something from San Diego?"
What did you-
I said sand.
(Drew gasps)
(audience gasps, applauds)
I tried.
And that's not all you brought here.
That's not all?
No, you also brought your friends and family who are here
in the audience, supporting you.
(audience cheering)
We don't travel alone.
(Ross laughs)
I'm so excited to have a piece of your home heart
right here.
Thank you, Shally, thank you so much.
You're welcome. You're welcome.
Well, we are newsies.
We are, we do the news.
That's what I've been doing for many, many,
many, many, many, many years.
I've been on your show many, many, many, many times
we are finally here together.
Shall we hit some headlines?
Let's do it.
Shally, let's do this.
All right.
(audience applause)
All right, Shally, up first, we've got a Boston couple
who didn't let a little thing like a blizzard
ruin their wedding.
Insider reports, Sally and Adam Irujo
were supposed to get married at the public library
in Providence, Rhode Island when a humungo snowstorm hit.
So they were holed up at the Hilton
with like 40 of their guests.
And you know what they decided to do?
Get married anyway.
(audience applause)
Yes, they did!
The wedding walked through the storm straight to the library
steps and the couple was married by Adam's dad.
And after the kiss Adam made it official
by pelting his wife with a snowball.
How romantic!
Don't you love this?
They said "Mother Nature, try it, try it.
It's not gonna happen."
You can't stop love.
Thank you so much.
Cannot stop love.
And pelting a snowball is one way to start a marriage.
I think this is, again, why this is so meaningful
to me, is it's memories.
How much more memorable is this wedding now?
Because of the visuals,
the sensorial,
this is incredible.
It's like a commercial.
Yeah, and so much of weddings nowadays
becomes so much about the party and inviting all the guests
but let's be real, that's marriage,
and you don't know what's gonna happen every day
and you just roll with it.
So if you can start your marriage like that, you're money.
Yeah. (audience applauds)
Is it true that you're a vow renewer?
Oh, you are?
I believe Shelly-
I officiate at weddings.
Yes.
You've officiated weddings?
I officiate weddings now.
And so you are, this is, I mean that's, what prompted...?
Followers and viewers, they started messaging me
and saying "I need you to..."
I'm a big fan of love
and people know that on social.
So they started messaging me and saying
"Would you marry us?"
And I'm like, "I'm just the news lady.
What do you mean marry you?" (laughs)
And they would not take no for an answer.
And the letters just kept coming and coming.
So I got licensed and now I officiate weddings.
I love this so much.
I'm such a romance, love junkie.
I just, I love it.
And I love that you did this.
Yes, being with people on the happiest day of their lives,
there's something so powerful about that.
My husband sometimes is like, "Honey we got the kids.
We gotta do this, and you're gonna do another wedding."
And I'm like, "But honey, it's love, it's love."
Shally, we should do a wedding here on show.
(Shally gasps)
(audience applauds)
We should do a wedding.
Yes, yes!
You know me, you know we're gonna make this happen.
Yes, I know you, it will happen.
All right, well, okay.
I think we have a lot on the menu
and yet there's still more headlines.
Hit it, Shally, your story.
Okay.
So I'm from California and we spend a lot
of time in our cars and there's some upsetting news.
I don't like to do upsetting news,
but I'm gonna do it today.
Carscoops reports that a new scientific study found
that your car is dirtier than a toilet.
No.
Uh-uh.
The research was conducted by Aston University
School of Biosciences, and in every single vehicle
they tested, I have to say this out loud,
they found fecal bacteria,
(Ross gags)
(audience gasps)
and they found it all over the place,
all over the place,
with the highest bacteria readings in the trunk.
Why in the trunk?
But then it's in the driver's seat.
It may make it make you think twice the next time
that you get that in and out food and you're eating and...
It makes sense.
Of course, we're pulling all this stuff.
Have we looked at our behavior?
I mean, and my kids, my car, oh my God.
It's insane how filthy my car is,
with the wrappers and the drive through and the boots
and the slices of pizza.
I mean, listen, hands up, who has a messy vehicle.
(Ross chuckles)
All right.
Obviously I'm saying this from this desk
and we just had that earlier discussion,
who here is completely clean
and free of fecal matter in your car?
Really?
Yeah, these scientists did not check my car.
I'm telling you right now.
I can guarantee it.
All right, Shelly, you have kids.
What's your car like?
I have kids, I have four kids.
There's like ketchup stuck on the ground.
Gum stuck somewhere.
It's a mess.
I have to wash my car litter every two hours
to keep it clean, you know.
Actually here's what I do now.
What?
I keep a roll of garbage bags.
Oh.
I do.
And I say, "That's it, everybody."
And they're nice little white garbage bags.
And I whip it out.
And I say, "Everybody, we are not getting out of this car,
if there is one thing that's not in the garbage bag."
Yes!
I hear you, I love that.
Okay, I grew, I learned, I changed.
Take a roll of little garbage bags in your vehicle.
And as far as the trunk, and the shoes, and the life,
and everything, just, you know,
get some wipes and do your best.
(upbeat music)